bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct -sans verte et france donc c'est
près de huit mille marocains qui tentent
de traverser la frontière espagnole
comment est ce que vous expliquez cette
arrivée soudaine de ces milliers de
migrants
merci beaucoup de me donner la parole je
veux souligner tout simplement quelque
chose d'emblée c'est que ce que nous
voyons tout de suite ce sont des
milliers d images évidemment très
sélective et j'exprime mon regret que je
lui dirai les mass médias d'europe en
particulier espagnols et quelques doses
quelques-uns d'autres ne voient que cet
aspect si vous voulez d'afflux de flux
migratoires qui arrive sur l'espagne
dans deux villes
évidemment dans deux villes je le tiens
à le préciser qu'ils sont ne l'oublions
pas marocains et non pas simplement sur
la côte méditerranée et qui sont des
enclaves espagnoles
il faut quand même rappeler la mémoire
et l'histoire ce sont deux villes
marocaines et cette foule qui
effectivement est entré ce c'est une
conséquence de la crise radicale de la
grande crise majeure qui existe entre le
maroc et l'espagne depuis bientôt
maintenant quatre ou cinq semaines et
vous savez pourquoi
tout simplement parce que l'espagne n'a
pas été je veux dire à la hauteur de ses
engagements dans ce sens dans le cadre
de son amitié de son partenariat
stratégique et exclusive avec le maroc
je souligne que l'espagne est
aujourd'hui la première puissance
économique
je veux dire premier partenaire
économique du maroc qui devance la
france donc ce n'est pas rien si vous
voulez la relation presque
je ne dirais pas simplement émotionnel
mais consanguine jeudi entre le maroc et
l'espagne
il se trouve que ce flou je veux dire ou
ce flux d'immigration qu' on a vu qu'à
auquel on assiste depuis lundi ce n'est
que le résultat si vous voulez de la
crise majeure la crise globale qui
existent entre les deux pays
féculent de crise les raisons de cette
crise justement est ce que c'est une
crise d'abord lié à la situation
économique mais aussi une crise
diplomatique puisque l'on sait que
l'espagne a accueilli le chef des
indépendantistes sahraouis du front pour
les armes à feu tout à fait c'est donc
un manque de confiance un manque de
respect si vous voulez des engagements
le chef du polisario qui est absolument
impliquer dans des danses jaillir des
procès qui est donc beaucoup de gens
réclament jeudi la justice et qui il est
venu en catimini avec un faux nom un
pseudonyme
avec des moyens je veux dire d'état
parce qu'il s'agit ça c'est presque un
complot d'état c'est d'état espagnols
qui qu'il a reçu avec tous les moyens
dont je dirai qui tu es en choquer les
marocains qui ont choqué le gouvernement
mais aussi le peuple marocain et donc ça
a posé le vrai problème
ensuite le le deuxième élément si vous
voulez de la crise c'est que ans et
jusqu'à aujourd'hui on s'est posé la
question est ce que ce monsieur va être
jugé ou non
finalement suite si vous voulez à cet
écran de crise qui a été donc celui de
du flux migratoires finalement je crois
que le juge espagnol n'est ce pas adms
sûrs et je veux dire là l'enjeu et a
décidé de le convoquer deux au combat je
veux dire de re de leurs convoqué pour
le 1er juin est ce qu en raison
justement de cette crise diplomatique
liée à la situation justement à
l'accueil de ce chef d indépendance
sahraouis du front polisario est ce que
d'une certaine façon on peut estimer que
le maroc tente de faire pression sur
l'espagne avec un c ces flux c'est un
flux massif de migrants l'espagne le
maroc n'est pas en mesure de l'empêcher
on peut un peu on peut le dire c'est pas
que l'état n'est pas en mesure de
l'empêcher mais on peut le dire aussi
que ça peut être ça pourrait être un
moyen de pression à moyen de ceux de
rappeler à l'espagne que le maroc a
aussi sans son langage si vous derrier
comme certains responsables européens
ont commencé à le faire depuis deux
jours sans langage guerrier
le maroc a aussi des moyens de pression
dans celui ci vous voulez d'immigration
n'oubliez pas que
le maroc a été il n'ya pas si longtemps
louis par tous les responsables de haut
niveau de l'europe l'union européenne
comme borel comme le vice président si
vous voulez quand même le président de
la commission européenne pour si vous
voulez son soutien sa politique
migratoire
le maroc est devenu forteresse jusqu'ici
c'est lui qui à arrêter l'immigration
et voilà maintenant nous n'avons reçu
vous avez vu l'image simplement de
marocains mais imaginez que demain ce
sont tous si vous voulez le sub
sahariens qui débarque et qui arrivait
que le maroc
ce jeudi les listes rentrer en espagne
ça va être la catastrophe des
manifestations qu' il ya beaucoup de
manifestations dans de nombreuses villes
espagnoles et le premier ministre
espagnol lui-même pedro sanchez qualifie
cette situation de crise majeure pour
l'espagne mais aussi l'europe est ce que
vous voyez là constaté chacun en matière
de politique migratoire pour l'union
européenne
en tout cas ce n'est pas le constat
d'échec ne peut pas être imputée au
maroc
moi je je suis absolument surpris étonné
voire choqué qu'un gouvernement entre
guillemets socialiste puis s'il vous
plaît jouer cette carte de populisme
parce que c'en est une
là haut lieu si vous voulez de dialoguer
avec le maroc qui est son partenaire au
lieu de d'écouter un petit peu si vous
voulez les griefs que le maroc formule à
l'égard si vous voulez des entorses qui
on est et qui ont été faites par rapport
à la politique de coopération de
partenariat dont se méfie toi mais c'est
aussi deux migrants ceci est le signe
d'une souffrance de la parade et
populace de la population marocaine qui
titille par finalement est ce que le
maroc n'a pas sa responsabilité le maroc
bien sûr à sa responsabilité mais est il
là je veux dire il la mesure et la
juguler si vous voulez c'est cette furie
un petit peu de gens mais de toute
manière en tout état de cause les gens
sont retournés chez eux il ya 4000 qui
ont été renvoyés donc on ne peut pas
considérer que c'est simplement le
besoin de partir identité le maroc
ça c'est un cliché n'est ce pas
aujourd'hui on a
peut montrer à l'espagne en particulier
à l'europe d'une manière générale que
nous le maroc a aussi si vous voulez des
moyens de rétorsion et que finalement
cette pression qui est fait sur lui
depuis des mois ne peut pas fonctionner
comme ça quand bien même les
fonctionnaires et elle est injuste parce
que quand vous faites la comparaison
avec la turquie
l'europe donne à la turque est
l'équivalent de 3 milliards de dollars
n'est ce pas pour évidemment jubilé tout
se fait d'immigrés at war venue de
l'acier et de l'irak et tout ça mais au
maroc l'europe a concédé et dernièrement
pas moi je veux dire pas plus que 380
millions d'euros alors il ya
déséquilibre
et puis en même temps une mauvaise foi
si vous voulez de l'europe qui joue un
petit pull la règle à jeudi qui joue un
petit peu la justice tout simplement par
rapport au maroc et qui est en train en
plus de se permettre de le critiquer et
de le condamner
et ce n'est pas normal très important
est ce qu'il ya une chance de devoir
résoudre justement cette la chance de
revoir et je sais que c'est qu'on
revienne à la raison garder le maroc
depuis 20 ans
souvenez vous en il y a eu depuis le roi
hassan ii est aujourd'hui avec le round
6 est donc les responsables espagnols et
majorité espagnols qui changent tous les
5 ans tous les quatre ans il y a
toujours eu et a toujours su si vous
voulez impact réel est plus que tacite
de coopération pour réguler pour régler
cette problématique migratoire maroc
c'est un partenaire sur ses marques
partenaires confiant voilà merci à vous
hassan alaoui d'avoir été en direct avec
nous je rappelle que vous êtes le
directeur de la publication de ma route
diplomatique spécialistes à des affaires
maghrébines et des relations
internationales